[Music]
hey good morning nice to see everyone
thanks for joining today I'll be talking
about the evolution of how companies are
using data leaks and some practices for
monitoring your data Lake it's better
and as you're running production loads
on it that you can be sure that things
are working so thanks for the intro my
name is Paul lapis and the CEO of a
company called intermix and we we
provide a dashboard for data engineers
to keep an eye on their mission-critical
data flows this talk is informed by our
experience working with a number of
innovative companies who are our
customers as well as ourselves we run a
pretty large scale data platform for
processing and analyzing data as well
and so to win in today's market
companies must build core competencies
in leveraging data this is no surprise
to any of us here data first companies
are dominating their industries and you
know we hear mentions of AI in earnings
calls and all over all over the place
when companies talk about how they think
about competing in the market the
category winners within each category
all share common characteristics a
they're really good at collecting data
they typically collect unique and
proprietary data within their particular
vertical they're really good at
processing that data at scale and
deriving insights from it and then
finally they you know they've been able
to accumulate the best people data
engineers data scientists data analysts
in order to make use of that data and
you know these are some of the customers
that we work with and don't take our
word for it you know these are the
companies that are winning in their own
markets
and doing some very interesting things
with data so these these trends in
leveraging data to compete into
in in your category have led to a shift
in how companies think about building
out their data platforms and the shift
is away from vertically integrated
products these are you know the mixed
panels the amplitudes of the world where
data integration processing and
dashboards all sort of were delivered as
one thing to and you know after that
monolithic data warehouses where all
data was stored within the data
warehouse to data Lake based
architectures so in a data Lake
traditional concepts of ETL are being
reimagined for a new world where a you
have source data residing in different
clouds third third party vendors third
party applications you have enormous
volumes of data you have terabytes of me
data arriving in all different formats
every single day with the expectation
that it will be stored forever
and the expectation that you know your
your data scientists can access it
forever very quickly and apply their
algorithms to where it lives and then
you know you also have rising workloads
do two demands of machine learning
companies want to leverage machine
learning and algorithms to it derive
insights from that data as well as the
democratization of data where everybody
in your company essentially wants wants
their own dashboard data lakes what
we've seen data links though all share
common characteristics a there's there's
an object store like s3 where raw and
unstructured data is being stored
forever number two is you have you know
you've got several analytical databases
or query processing engines that operate
on that data and you know warehouse it
and finally you have an orchestration
layer that coordinates how data flows
through those various databases to
implement the the various processing
requirements for the various models that
that you're putting into production so
you know what we have seen in our
experience is that the adoption of data
Lake and data Lake initiatives have have
accelerated significantly in the past
twelve months it's been pretty pretty
quick and we think this is happening now
you know quickly for three reasons
as3 if you're talking about Amazon Web
Services s3 is the cheapest possible
place to store your data for ever and
really you know there's a trade-off
between speed and perform speed and cost
and so you only want to pay for fast
queries when you need fast queries so
you may as well just store everything in
s3 number two is that one of the one of
the biggest challenges of processing
data at scale is data movement getting
data from women from one place to
another sometimes is impossible
oftentimes it takes a lot longer you
know might take hours in order to get
data from one place to another
leveraging the in-house capabilities of
your various databases is more and more
important to bring your algorithms into
the database where the data already sits
or into the area where the data already
sits so that you don't have to move the
data around so there's the best tool for
the job and you want to be able to use
that tool without moving data and that's
the number of tools are also
proliferating and then finally you've
got different audiences right as your
company grows and demand for data grows
within your organization your data
scientists versus your data engineers
versus business analysts all want to
interact with the data in different ways
using different programming languages
and different tools and so that has led
to a need to support various interfaces
and systems on these data links so let's
sort of make it real for a second I
wanted to share a common pattern tech
stack that we RC
merge with the companies that we work
with and the companies that we talk to
and at the very at the very basic level
there's an object store there's s3 and
we think about workloads in two
categories batch workloads we're you
know where you're continuously running
the same job on a data set to move it
along to implement a model and then your
interactive use cases a warehouse is
used most often to store aggregated and
pre process data that is you know the
main source usually for business
analysts and others to connect to we see
Amazon redshift is being really you know
one of the biggest and most popular it's
being used for both interactive and best
use cases Hadoop and EMR is increasingly
being used for batch use cases to
largely as the first stage in a data
pipeline it's really good at processing
very long tables at aggregating very
very high amounts of large amounts of
events and so we see sparks equal Scala
and Python being implemented on top of
EMR in order to implement pipeline
stages where you know you just don't
want to store that raw data in a data
warehouse it's just too expensive it
takes too long we see presto
accelerating in popularity or athina
which is the Amazon service that
implements that you know uses presto on
the backend presto is becoming very
popular and the companies that we work
with because you can access the data
where it lives you don't have to move
data to actually query it and you're
able to join data from different data
sets with one single statement so it's
pretty slow in some cases because of the
way that is implemented but it's very
very useful for interactive use cases
and then finally there's an
orchestration layer that will manage the
the the task of storing your jobs your
batch jobs and then executing them
within a dag
you implement your various models the
technology that we see gaining more
traction in the open-source world is
Apache airflow and so you know we see
this so much we've given it a name we
call it the pair stack and let me just
sort of pause for a second and see a
show of hands how many people in this
room are using at least one of these
technologies at the moment cool and then
keep your hands up if you're using all
of them alright so hey so cool alright
so there's some adoption of these
technologies here as well so let me talk
about how the stack is being used so
unlike end-user applications data apps
run jobs on this on this stack there's
three categories of data apps the first
being data integration services this is
vendors and tools that move application
raw data into your data Lake from
external systems number two is analysis
tools that connect to your data
warehouse or connect to any any of the
systems in this in the stack - you know
to analyze data and get data out and
then finally there's a work flow
appreciation that we just talked about
these are systems that implement
workflows now monitoring the performance
of these data applications is just as
critical if you know if data is
important to your business and if you
are working on data projects where the
reliability and performance of data is
important then monitoring the
performance of these data applications
is critical to making sure that that
things are working well and so that's
what we're gonna talk about next so the
fundamental problem you know that we are
solving as data engineers is to ensure
that the data pipelines are working
right to ensure that the models that
were implementing that we're processing
within these data lectures is working so
we want to answer questions like our
data flows operating normally our data
app is able to access data what is what
is the service level of the user
and any applications that are actually
running queries on these systems and
what are my cost drivers right what am i
spending for all of this technology and
how do I like think about attributing
the cost of this technology to the
various teams and users that are using
it the stuff is is getting more and more
expensive as you're storing more and
more data in order to accomplish this
you need you need new types of metrics
traditional metrics like network
utilization CPU utilization are more or
less irrelevant when you're thinking
about monitoring data leaks because
you're not monitoring network packets
you're monitoring how an individual you
know event will flow through your system
and be processed and aggregated as it
flows from its source to its destination
so any any system where you're going to
keep an eye on what's happening in the
data lake must consider new types of
data number one is you need to actually
understand what the jobs are that are
being run the syntax and actual text of
the sequel queries that are running as
well as performance characteristics of
those queries themselves whatever
database they ran and you want to
understand well you know what was the
performance of that query what were the
resources used for that query and then
what were there any issues related to
that number two is you know our in in in
our experience our customers run about 2
million queries every week on these
systems some more and that's a lot of
queries and typically there's dozens of
applications that are running queries
and understanding which application is
running what query so that you can map
the contexts of that user in the
application that's running the query
down to how well it executed when you're
talking about running a model across
multiple databases is really hard so you
need some way to associate who run that
who ran that job back up to the end user
of the data application and we'll talk
about one approach to doing
and then finally because your jobs are
operating on data this could be data
within a relational database it could be
it could be a partition within a hive
meta store it could be any any data set
that that is being queried or accessed
you also need to trend and track the
size and the characteristics of the
underlying data store that is being
operated on because often times changes
in in the in the in the structure of
that data or how the data is laid out
impact the performance of the jobs that
are querying it so for example if you
know you're in redshift and you're
querying a table and that table is
growing very quickly a number of rows
the queries that are scanning it are
going to get slower if you're running a
spark sequel job on top of s3 and the
layout of your you know say that using
you know sort of using parquet and
you've selected the wrong partition
scheme for s3 then that query is gonna
run really really slowly so you need to
you know be able to understand how those
things are linked together and to be
able to link what queries are running
out what tables so you know if if you're
running production data and your company
is relying on it you there's essentially
three problems that you want to solve I
talked about them here cost efficiency
and SLA and I'll sort of dive into them
a little bit so service level agreement
users of your data applications are not
always part of your team they're part of
teams outside of your team and so they
expect a certain minimum level of
service when they're accessing the data
so this involves query speed this
involves data freshness this involves
reliability of the actual data when it's
being queried and so really you need to
know am i meeting my SLA right what is
the performance of these various users
are my and you know how are these things
trending over time is is this particular
model the
areas you know jobs that implement this
model are they getting slower over time
are they getting faster over time do you
even know what are the biggest
bottlenecks if things start going wrong
what is the root cause of why things
start going wrong the efficiency is a
big a big a big a big problem what I
mean is when there's problems how
quickly can you isolate where the
problem is and what's causing it and do
you know if problems before your users
tell you we hear often times that you
know users will complain about slow
queries or inaccessible queries or the
database is down or whatever and what
ends up happening is you know the folks
that are responsible for the data stack
now have to stop what they're doing and
go off and troubleshoot and figure out
what's wrong but what if you had a
system that where you could be alerted
automatically when things started going
wrong and be able to pinpoint very very
quickly what the source of that problem
was so you know why are my model slow
why is this query failing where do I
have contention issues etc cost we see
is becoming a bigger and bigger problem
you know understanding what's driving
the cost of this system will help you
answer questions like why are we
spending so much are we over subscribed
in certain areas of the system are we
under subscribed if if we need to add
resources somewhere what's the best
place to add resources and how does that
impact the the performance of the models
or the queries that we're running and
then finally these problems that I just
described they get bigger over time
right they don't get smaller they get
bigger as you add more workloads to the
system the demand for the data goes up
as you add more data more data sources
third-party tools I'm referring to tools
like segment tools like a luma 5 trend
tools that are being used to move data
into your system oftentimes these jobs
are written by third parties that don't
work for your company and so you kind of
need to know what they're doing on the
system to the extent that they might be
running wasteful
pensive and inefficient queries that's
that's that's like visibility that you
need to have so that you're not
surprised later by some action that was
taken back so let's sort of dive into
SLA so here are some examples of data
applications that we we see growing in
popularity across the three categories
of applications that I talked about
across data integration services
workflow orchestration and the analysis
tools now I really recommend that you
think about having a dashboard that
contains data like this in your
environment it's not that trivial to
build but this is what this is what I
see as being something that will really
help you keep an eye on really what's
going on in your system so across
monitoring the performance of queries
ranking how things are changing over
time and then spotting issues very very
quickly it's super important right so
you want to have a dashboard that
aggregates all this stuff for you in one
place so what is the average latency
trended over time of my key workflows
and my key models and my key users how
does my utilization of my various
databases storage and database systems
how does that how does that map to the
the performance of queries we're you
know we're running different apps on
these systems and dashboards and models
it's very useful to know which ones are
the most expensive which ones are the
slowest so that you can go tackle those
for optimization which of my users are
the most wasteful there's typically an
8020 rule and most of these things where
20% of your users and 20% of your jobs
eat up 80% of your utilization and your
resources so understanding who and what
those are is really useful and then
finally two of the biggest problems that
create issues in these data stacks is
contention and then resource starvation
so contention could be queuing in
redshift or in presto where you've got a
lot of jobs that are all aligning that
exceed the
concurrency configuration for that
particular database that creates
bottlenecks or when you run out of
resources either dis space utilization
you went out of you know your star for
IO or CPU and some and some database
system and then you know where my job's
failing where's the pipeline getting
stuck and which which you know at sort
of which stage is that happening so I
wanted to introduce a concept of a way
to see into which app is running queries
using query annotations this is
something that we're seeing more and
more applications provide query
annotations essentially I'm talking
about adding a comment to a sequel query
that contains metadata about who ran
that sequel query this this is a vendor
agnostic way of adding context to a
query to understand where it came from
so anything can be annotated obviously
the name of the app the user that that
was logged into the application that ran
the app which is really hard to see the
the name of the task or the job or the
dag that's running another metadata that
can help you sort of pinpoint who's
actually running this job so this can
help you answer answer a lot of
questions that you can't get just by
looking at the jobs and the queries from
the actual query engine itself right
there's so many queries it's impossible
to actually carve it up without without
some way of annotating these jobs so a
number of dashboards include annotations
now by default here are some examples
I'll let you deduce which is which some
are better than others if you do choose
to add annotations in your own systems
you see style comments because if new
lines get stripped from the sequel text
when you're parsing it then if you're
using - - comments you won't know when
the comment ends in the sequel begins
and then you know use some structured
format like you know like JSON if you're
using Apache airflow here is you know an
example schema that is very very useful
and we've written in our company we we
have plugins you know we support
annotations in our product and we've
written a number of helper libraries in
ways to add annotations using Python so
after this talk if you want more
information on using these just get in
touch with me and I'll sort of share
some more information on that for you
talking about efficiency so you know
quickly understanding where problems are
and whether what caused their problems
is is is is what I wanted to talk about
next do you ever wonder is my query
latency growing do I have issues on the
system across my various databases or
queries failing why are they failing to
illustrate how hard it is an important
it is I wanted to go through a
troubleshooting scenario where say you
have one of your models
takes ten minutes to run say think 60
minutes to run and all of a sudden that
started it's slower by 20% you know you
wake up in the morning and all of a
sudden this you know this dag is much
slower than it was and that's and that's
creating issues for you so you're going
through the five why's process you ask
well why is it slower so I'm gonna walk
through sort of some of these five whys
and then and then talk about what you
know what are some of the metrics that
we need in order to actually answer
these questions so my dad gets slower by
20%
well that's because one of the tasks
within this dag experience of 4x latency
spike okay great so I understand that
that latency of the entire model dag was
caused by this one task well why did
that one task
slowed down by 4x well that's because
one of the queries within that
transaction went from 10 you know went
from 10 seconds to 3 minutes so we can
isolate within that task well which is
the job that was taking longer what did
that happen well one of the of the
tables that this query was
anning went from 10 million rows to 1
billion rows in less than a day so all
of a sudden some table started growing
that causes career to go slower okay
great what did that happen well there
was another query query one two three
that started inserting data into this
table over the past day and then who ran
that query like what where did that
query come from so we can see that that
query was run by you know an individual
using read ash that was inserting data
into this table so very quickly we can
isolate okay we know that there's a
problem we can isolate it down to it
being caused by this one query this one
job being run by this person named
Jordan and so we can only sort of stitch
this data together if we're monitoring
using the metrics that we talked about
earlier right for step one we we need to
understand the query Layton sees for
certain DAGs and be able to know in to
enter and to annotate those jobs so we
can understand well which which model or
these queries are part of the same thing
with step two to understand that a table
was growing we we have to trend the size
of table and the real kind of a table
over time so that we can sort of track
the growth of that step four
you need to map we need to understand
for for this query statement it was
inserting table into this you know data
into this particular table so that we
can map those two things together and
then annotations we'll use that again in
order to actually figure out which data
was inserting into it you know this is
this is a simplified example but this
kind of thing happens all the time
across you know you see it happening
constantly across many different
databases and systems it would take
somebody hours if ever it's really
diagnosed that this was the cause of a
particular model or query slowing down
but if you have this data at your
fingertips you can you can get the data
much you know you can actually isolate
that much more quickly so some advanced
testing but that I'm not going to talk
about here but I wanted to point out
that we're seeing more and more people
doing that you should be doing some
level of this in your environment
is data validation itself you know
actually doubt actually validating that
the results of your aggregations or are
producing their correct results in that
as your ETL and data from one source to
a destination that you're capturing all
the rows as some very very simple
examples data validation is becoming a
bigger problem as we're putting more
things into production in the anomaly
detection right like how do I sort of
understand when when the behavior of the
system is changing if I'm inserting a
thousand rows per day into this table
and that goes down to ten that probably
is an indicator of an issue so talking
about costs so there's there's a
trade-off between how fast a query is
and query speed and how and what that
query costs are run if you're if you're
querying s3 data that lives in necessary
with presto
that's pretty inexpensive if we're
querying it it with Amazon redshift
that's a lot more expensive because
redshift storing data live in redshift
is more expensive than s3 so it's
important for us to think about this in
the context of all the various use cases
and jobs running on the system there's
some queries that you don't want to pay
a lot of money for but sometimes adding
you know you know moving a particular
workload to a different database will
make it run much faster but
understanding what's driving those costs
is super important um you know why track
query cost you can make you know make
decisions on where to invest in order to
speed things up you can charge back to
other departments in your company that
are using these data platforms like you
can you can you know sales and marketing
teams that are using half of your data
processing engine you know you might go
get some budget for them and then also
it'll help you sort of answer the
question of what is it gonna cost me to
increase the recency of my data you know
if you want to move a table from being
one day old or it's being updated daily
to being updated every four hours or
every one hour there's a huge cost to
that because it means you have to run
more jobs on the system in order to
speed up the recency and that doesn't
grow linearly you know adding you know
how could you know quadrupling the
number of jobs in the system it doesn't
mean that your cost will go up by 4x it
might mean that it'll okay that it'll go
up by a lot more than that so
understanding what those drivers are is
super super important when you know one
pattern that we see a lot is you know
the shift that we were seeing away from
monolithic data warehouses to data lakes
where all raw data used to be stored in
rest shift and now it's just being
stored in s3 and one of the of the big
use cases we see is sort of moving raw
data processing out of red shift into
Hadoop so if you have if you're
processing say for example mobile events
and you're getting you know 100 million
events a day then aggregating that to
down to a five minute window is really
easy in Hadoop it's much more expensive
and hard to do in redshift and so those
are some of the first workloads that
that we're seeing laughs and if you do
that you'll end up being able to reduce
a lot of nodes in your redshift Buster
because you won't need to have it to
Annie as much storage online so you can
you can you can delete nodes measuring
cost of a query is hard because
different databases or different query
engines are different they have
different cost drivers a few examples in
Amazon redshift the the cost driver is
the number of nodes that you have in
your cluster and so the metrics that you
need to track for a query or different
are you need to know how many rows it's
scanning or how much memory it's using
so that you can help to figure out what
is the relative expense of this query
over another query in Amazon Athena your
cost driver is just your s3 storage and
so there we you know what you need to
track is is how many bytes are being
processed by this particular query or
how many columns are being accessed by
it which
which will drive up the number of bytes
in impress though your cost driver is
more complicated because presto users
databases as its catalog and so you need
to sum the cost of the various queries
on each of the databases that that press
though is accessing in addition to the
internal handling of that statement
within the Presto workers themselves and
so-and-so tracking that is much more
complicated and so you know tracking
metrics for each of these queries within
each database is really really important
so that's that's it I wanted to
introduce you or to offer we have a
weekly newsletter that goes out to about
5,000 people with really high open rates
if you have any content that you're
publishing or blog posts that you've
written we would be more than happy to
just shoot that into our newsletter that
goes out weekly just email submissions
at SF data that I owe and then we'll get
it in there it's a really great
community of data engineers so that's it
thank you very much
[Applause]
you